un accord aux résultats probants mais
qui tend les relations gréco turques
depuis sa signature après la crise
migratoire de 2015 le nombre d'arrivées
de migrants en grèce a chuté de façon
spectaculaire en 2020 dix mille
personnes ont traversé la mer egée ces 8
146 mille de moins qu'en 2015
en contrepartie l'europe s'était engagé
à verser deux tranches de 3 milliards
d'euros pour aider la turquie à
accueillir ces réfugiés
pour sa part la turquie souhaite
renégocier le montant des aides
financières et les délais de versement
elle estime ce pacte aujourd'hui caduque
nous sommes le pays qui accueille le
plus de réfugiés au monde avec notamment
3 27 millions de syriens
cela nous a coûté plus de 40 milliards
d'euros une somme à comparer avec des 6
milliards d'euros dead européenne
promise dans l'accord de 2016 dont
pratiquement la moitié n'a pas encore
été dépensés
il faut un partage équitable du fardeau
entre la turquie et le reste de l'europe
nous sommes convaincus que le
renouvellement de l'accord du 18 mars
2016 est impératif est dans l'intérêt de
tous de son côté la grèce appelle la
turquie à reprendre 1450 migrants
actuellement sur son sol le ministre
grec en charge des questions migratoires
et de l'asile insiste sur l'importance
d'une application convenable de l'accord
signé le 18 mars 2016 les états en
première ligne doivent à la fois
protéger leurs frontières mené les
procédures d'asile procéder au retour et
intégrer ceux qui ont droit à la
protection internationale
clairement nous ne pouvons pas faire
tout cela nous ne pouvons pas avoir à
nouveau un million d'arrivées en europe
comme en 2015
il est déterminant de renforcer les
relations avec les pays d'origine et les
pays de transit
du côté européen josep borrell a tenu à
rappeler l'importance des efforts de
chaque partie pour garantir et prolonger
la réussite de cet accord entre la grèce
et la turquie
nous devons travailler pour une
migration sur juste et régulière nous
devons mettre en place des mesures
incitatives pour que les pays tiers
accepte les personnes qui doivent
retourner dans leur pays et pour créer
un flux de migration régulière qui
permet aux personnes de voyager sans
avoir à risquer leur vie
le sommet européen qui aura lieu les 25
et 26 mars prochain sera consacré à la
relation entre l'union européenne et la
turquie
ursula von der leyen les charles michel
doit s'entretenir en visioconférence ce
vendredi avec richesse tayyip erdogan